[Music]
what's up Wolfgang so just like I said
in one of my previous videos as Deadpool
2 gets closer they're going to have more
TV spot trailers and promotions going on
and like I said if they keep releasing
them I'll keep making videos on them to
make sure you all see them so here we go
shall they Lutz
this is insane think of it as teamwork
the key was to keep it subtle think of
this as a special Deadpool present for
your 659 million fans worldwide Reena
no penises day what in the Pogba they're
not wearing the official Deadpool
kneepads I know they don't wear kneepads
but they sure as do now
I love Josie's head for this Josie I
personally love this promotion I love
how it's making fun of advertising and
promotions while simultaneously being an
advertisement and a promotion in itself
and it's just great because Deadpool is
the only one that could pull it off it's
the only movie and character that can
pull off these sarcastic and ironic
commercials and that's just the fun of
Deadpool that's the greatness of his
character you can do so much with it
like the fact that this is also a
Manchester United promotion and to me
it's hilarious it's Deadpool being extra
he's just doing all that he can to
promote his movie it even talks about
knee pads soccer players not wearing
knee pads and he says he knows that but
he has to be an infinity war see when
you make a sequel you have to double
down in your promotions or you just get
buried by infinity war that's a great
joke in its own I love that and it's
great because he's technically not in
the MCU but I mean I consider him like
an honorary MCU character I mean he's in
the same universe in the comics and I
was low-key kind of hoping that Deadpool
would show up with Lady Death and
infinity war somehow but I knew they
wouldn't throw in that kind of crazy
weird awesome story so wishful thinking
so that's it hope you're excited for
Deadpool too it comes out in just a few
days and I hope you enjoyed this video
if you did please give it a thumbs up
for me also if you want to stay up to
date with Deadpool too and you just
enjoy Marvel and superhero videos and
want to see more subscribe to my channel
also don't forget about our speaker
giveaway the details are in the
description below thank you so much for
watching
woof woof hello friends
I'm back that is the most beautiful
thing I've ever heard I want some more
daddy's got this
so be fun